chemistry is at the heart of the very
controversial world of energy one Nobel
laureate who's been considering biofuels
as one important solution for the world
is Steven Chu who advises the White
House
she's quite amazing he got the Nobel
Prize for Physics for being able to cool
down atoms using energy and then he put
his energy into renewable energy and
then he became a policy maker under
Barack Obama as a secretary of energy
for the United States managing everyone
who works in renewables
but a laureate who on the other hand
sees biofuels as a relatively trivial
factor is heart but Mikkel
so I hear mikela is pretty sceptic about
biofuels they thinks we should use
nature to build more complicated things
but he does say that nature is good at
making things I think they can harness
that
biofuels is making a liquid fuel that is
not made from petroleum petroleum comes
from the ground and when you burn it
you're taking carbon from the ground and
putting it into the air and that is a
problem in terms of climate change
because it's a greenhouse gas if we can
instead use plants to take co2 from the
air put into plants and then if we can
convert that into a liquid fuel that is
a biofuel
and then when you burn it you'll get co2
again but it'll just go right back into
the air the plant will take it again and
we can turn it into a fuel so we have a
renewable process half of the energy in
the body food comes actually from fossil
fuels because in it fertiliser unit
vector fuel and everything costs energy
if all the agriculture land of Germany
is used for producing biofuel
we only can substitute maybe eight to
ten percent of the German diesel and
gasoline used by cars if we want to have
a car powered by a renewable fuel we can
use a biomass in existing technology
like we have a car right here we do not
have to scrap all the cars and build a
brand new one with a huge battery pack
that won't work everywhere and I'm not
saying that biofuels need to replace a
hundred percent of our current petroleum
needs but I think there are times when
we need the energy density and there is
efficiency in being able to use current
infrastructure like this car alright I
have to argue against that if you use a
biomass for heating purposes and you
save heating oil or when you use the
biomass in power station to generate
electricity you buy a rule out by a
factor of three better then when you go
buy a buy food in reducing the carbon
dioxide when you already have current
technology which exists which also drive
on the road battery cars or hydrogen
cars they also exist right it's not
likely to technology that needs to be
invented it's already there and for sure
the technology is not going to change
within a day so you say I'm going to
scrap all the cars nobody's talking
about scrapping all the car
but if we invest into that then
eventually step-by-step is going to be
changing from standard gasoline car into
hydrogen cars or battery cars we don't
have to invest anything to teach the
grass to sequester carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere it can do that right now
yeah but we can do better and we're
working on it very low efficiency you
only pay less than 1% of the huns
energies in the grass but in terms of
return on investment I don't have to do
anything to get that to take Europe
Western Europe you don't have a lot of
grasslands the to spare much of the bio
mass research and biofuels research
we're doing is to use to coexist with
agriculture so the corn will be used for
feed for humans feed for animals and the
corn cobs the corn stover if you can
economically convert that you still have
the some costs of the tillage and the
fertilizer and all those other things
and so under that perspective you have
agricultural residues if you can make it
commercially viable then the conflict
between food and fuel begins to diminish
a lot it's kind of like a band-aid it's
right now we're using natural
photosynthesis and that's the that's
what we have is technology and we're
trying to make an artificial
photosynthetic system that we will
eventually be able to make fuel at a
higher efficiency than Nature can but
until we get there we have to use the
band-aid of biofuels well that's another
possibility that if you can use direct
sunlight the fuels if you cancel a very
efficiently use renewable electricity to
fuels and to convert something you know
to liquid filled liquid fuel we all
concede will be with us for a while
especially with airplanes there's no
debate
you need liquid fuel let's have fixate
only on biofuels particularly you know
how do you make liquid transportation
fuel in a renewable way in this case
what I would do is you would simply use
for the Royal tart shells electrolyze
water and take the hydrogen take the
carbon dioxide for a nearby power
station cressida power station and
convert the co2 into methane or methanol
methanol you have a liquid you have a
liquid which you can directly using that
in an ignition engine and that's the way
in the future I think methanol can be a
starting point yeah
ultimately I think for airplanes you
need higher density yeah methanol
ethanol or to low density so biofuels
use natural photosynthesis to get energy
in the same way that oil does but
artificial photosynthesis is a man-made
alternative to natural photosynthesis
and the way that we make artificial
photosynthetic systems is we have two
reactions that we use to split water
into hydrogen which we can use as fuel
that's what they use as jet fuel and we
also have to oxidize the water and one
of the major problems that we're having
right now is we need to find a suitable
artificial photosynthetic system that
can make fuel cheaply and this can be
coupled affordable take systems and a
lot of the research that Penn and I do
is related to that in an artificial
photosynthetic system you'd have to have
for example water oxidizing reaction and
then you'd have to have a fuel producing
reaction at the cathode and that fuel
produced reaction could create hydrogen
but there's also research being done
trying to make liquid fuels at the cast
cathode rather than hydrogen and I think
that that is probably the way of the
future but there are a lot of basic
research steps we have to take before we
can realize a fully a highly efficient
artificial photosynthetic system system
mimicking a natural photosynthesis you
need too many photons for producing
hydrogen yeah and the other features of
the course is very low it's lower than
the electrolysis of water combined to a
photovoltaic cell yeah but the trouble
with the electrolysis water the way we
currently know how to do it efficiently
is you use very expensive that's there
are many many people building catalyst
and I'm pretty optimistic that this is
soft on a catalytic process so we're
working on a photo of a chemical cell to
have able to make both electricity and
fuel and what do you think about
hydrogen economy or original base
fueling systems basically transforming
from a carbon-based directly to the
other because we can produce the origin
and we are more and more able to put the
system more efficiently you know I would
test for scientists if you're working on
every day s what's the price point in
the production of hydrogen per kilogram
if they say I don't have any ideas and
said you should think about that it's
not gonna get started it's like if I
produce biofuels at six dollars a gallon
you never you're gonna get started if
you don't know that
you should start knowing that it's the
economic drivers people make choices
countries make sure it's companies make
choices because of the economics of it
you're not gonna ask them to spend twice
as much money to do something some
consumers well do that a very small
fraction but most people say what's the
bottom line the bottom line I'm willing
to pay the same maybe a team or but not
not hugely different but the thing is
technology can do this they can you can
make clean energy as inexpensive as
fossil energy I'm still a proponent for
the purely electrical way so use the
electricity from photovoltaics or say or
also from thermal solar energy
conversion generate electricity and then
you search petabytes across the weak
point is the better is the the energy
density of the battery is too low but it
can be increased by a factor of ten in
addition you have to consider that the
the ignition engines are pretty
inefficient only twenty percent of the
energy of the fuel is used to drive the
wheel eighty percent of the energy of
the battery store the better issues
divided the wheel so we have an
additional factor of four in favor of
the purely electrical schema well fuel
cells can solve that issue but you also
have the energy of a chemical bond will
always be better
ultimately theoretically you can always
store more store more energy in the
chemical bond rather than you couldn't
for example lithium-ion battery
particularly at this meeting people have
been emphasizing right Elysium is not so
abundant so much of it it's pollution
again if you don't consider the cost for
the battery driving your car would by
fact often cheaper if you
simply use electricity then you go to
the gasoline station but there but the
cost of the batteries come down and to
folders it's gonna come down another two
fold I don't fully buy the argument that
we don't have enough Elysium because we
know I don't know if I don't buy that at
all and it's not even clear that lithium
will be the end point technology the
battery a kind of is fascinating because
we are looking very closely to all the
technology that everyone has mentioned
in the Department of Energy and if we
knew for sure that we could get a
battery that's even four times higher
density it works at a wide temperature
range that's one quarter the cost that
will change everything if we knew all
these things any you know two or three
of them you can change a lot of things
but what's fascinating is and everything
that our parents said we do not know for
sure although I agree cost is a
significant issue I don't think that we
as scientists have the ability to
estimate how much will it cost to
produce it on a large scale and only
once it reaches the industry then you
can have some assessments of whether or
not it's effective or not it starts in
the lab using first row transition
metals staying away from very expensive
elements and then it gradually makes its
way to industry scale only you know we
know you know you tell me you you have a
system you can economically scale to
hydrolyze water now and make hydrogen I
would say you should be selling as a
business there's price points and
hydrogen they're well known you can sell
that to petroleum refining companies you
can sell that to fuel cells and you
should be making lots of money okay it
does not it does not exist and if it
does you know at least very least get a
grant from the Department of Energy
now with shale gas will this all be moot
will we not be able to reach those price
points to make these renewable we will
the shale gas has actually gone into oil
there's much more production of oil in
the odd sites has gone up 800,000
barrels a day it's gonna go up another
age
we're the second biggest oil producer in
the world now because of shale oil
despite that the it's it's not a big
enough wrinkle to alter the world oil
prices which is an international price
but what about altering people like in
the United States our congressman's
opinion of whether or not to fund
renewable research that might be for
different reasons we as scientists can
get the technology I think the the
government I have faith at least that
the government's will be able to enact
the policies if the technology is there
no actually what my dream would be if
superconducting cables should be
spending the globe then you need a few
for the world high fields worldwide is
polluted all over globe one is layer one
in Japan in China one in Sahara one in
Arizona Mexico if you can even have DC
underwater without increase and I know
that in Moroccan there's a Caribbean
Spain another one between Tunisia and
Italy and so undersea cables keep on
that's going to have more face that
we're gonna find a good artificial
photosynthetic system before we find a
room-temperature superconductor that's
really cheap and they can have high
current and that can have ikura genie
high TC so our challenge is scientists
is to make it look good enough for the
companies or the government to invest I
think well you have to look at how
technology gets developed first of all
it gets developed not because there's
some magical research done in a
university or a national lab or
something and then voila you have it
it's something that gets established and
then you learn from it evolves and
evolves over tens of years to a half a
century it's evolving there's not a
single thing that's happening what kind
of damage do you think will do to our
environment while we're waiting for all
this doing a lot of things in the
meantime and the batteries are improving
the price of batteries went down to
folding last four
five years fights of solar modules went
down fourfold in the last four years
okay the electronics that are needed for
DC transmission are coming down
dramatically all these things are
happening and you just accelerated you
you just accelerate that technology
development the thought of cells they
went down because they become on a lot
of scale but do you know what the first
silicon efficiencies were and solar
photovoltaics about one or two percent
yes now you have in bulk mass production
16% going to 20% okay to to 20% you do
that ten fold induction the cost has
dropped several hundred fold in
productions from the 50s and 62 now this
is huge it's not clear where the
solution is going to come from and there
won't be a single solution we will need
many solutions we will need solutions we
talked about in transmission in energy
storage and better solutions in the
generation of clean energy and energy
efficiency which we haven't talked about
you know dramatic improvements are
waiting actually to just be used but
also invented so all of these things are
real need and if you know paraphrase
myself there's necessities and mother of
all inventions we got the mother of all
necessities in climate change as I told
my students and postdocs over the last
25 years the greatest danger most of us
lies not in setting our aim too high and
falling short but in setting our aim too
low and achieving our mark that was said
by Michelangelo so you students remember
that fail fail fast move on but set your
aim high so if I dedicate my life to
working on renewable energy you think
that I'm serving the country in the
world
yes absolutely especially if you succeed
you